Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill where
Congress is returning after its August
recess the immigration issue is the
latest addition to a calendar that is
already jam-packed Nancy good morning
good morning that's right even before
hurricane Harvey hit Congress was facing
a very daunting September agenda they
need to raise the debt ceiling and fund
the government to things that can be
pretty controversial with conservatives
and now on top of that they've got this
new request from the White House more
than seven billion dollars essentially a
down payment on relief funding for
hurricane victims in Texas now that
funding has a lot of support from both
sides so congressional leaders are
thinking that they'll roll it into a
bill to raise the debt ceiling but
thought being that the Texas aid will
make it harder for anyone to vote no on
the larger bill Republican leaders are
hoping to get all of this out of the way
quickly without a fight because what
they really want to focus on this fall
is tax reform dramatically lowering the
corporate rate and individual rates - a
chance for what you might call a
Republican do-over after the party's
plan to repeal Obamacare fell apart this
summer all of this is sure to come up
when congressional leaders meet with the
president at the White House later today
Jeff Nancy Cordes thank you very much